taylor hearn his sick start of the
season 37th game overall you can see him
there with a three and four record 71
punch out so far for this lefty in 70
and two thirds innings
his numbers are really good and he
strikes out brantley that is out number
two
that's a big fastball from taylor herm
below the zone something we don't see
too often from michael brantley where he
chases
but he had a decision to make and not a
lot of time to do it at 96 miles an hour
a little bit of movement that looked
like the two seam grip from taylor
trying to go to 4-0 and his four starts
against the texas rangers his previous
three this year all came at minutemate
park first and third nobody out for
dulles garcia who was two for four with
a home run yesterday
and that ball smashed into left field
that's a base hit hernandez scores
easily from third connor falefa hustling
his way to third base and adolesce
garcia has the rangers on the board
first this afternoon it's one nothing
just really great approaches all the way
around here from these rangers hitters
the first three of the game against zach
wreck you were talking about not trying
to get too far out in front of pitches
as a change up at 86 and one that is
middle in to garcia and if that swing
gets too big and it gets too anxious he
gets out in front of that pitch but
instead he's right on time squares it up
and gets himself that rbi single all
right so the rangers for the first
inning run
still nobody out for nathaniel lowe
and he bloops this one short left field
brantley gets to it isaiah tagging he
heads to the plate throw comes through
he'll score garcia going to second and
the throw goes into center field and
adolesce garcia will head to third
a sac fly for low rangers lead at two
nothing and houston having a little time
of it in the first
the mistake here was not cutting that
ball off and then maldonado made it
worse by the bathroom that he made out
the second base great base running by
garcia you're going to see this
sacrifice fly and michael brownlee just
does not have that strong of an arm
isaiah kind of left was a great runner
it's a bad read from alex bregman that
throw was offline he needs to cut that
off himself he doesn't as you're gonna
see michael brantley get behind this
baseball look where bregman is he knows
that ball is not on target so at that
point he lets it go
it's a good read by garcia he would have
been safe at second that throw gets away
and he ends up at third base sacrifice
fly
and dj peters with a chance to add on
here
this ball hit hard that one into left
field it will head all the way to the
fence another run is in peters
in the second with the rbi double
and the rangers have a three-nothing
lead they'd love to see it some of these
young ranger hitters doing damage
against the veteran zach frankie this
pitch ended up being a front door
breaking ball and really kind of
finished inner third as that cranky was
trying to go away and some very very
comfortable swings here this afternoon
as that ball is hammered off the bat at
dj peters grenkey the veteran he's not
having any fun yet this afternoon with
just one out the rangers leading 3-0
there's a big swing by dj peters that
ball heading out to the alley left
center and caught up against the wall
jake myers what a play to give up his
body for the out
it'll go as a sack fly for peters
rangers pick up their fourth run
[Applause]
but the former husker went in hard into
that wall to make that play
this was an incredible play so much hang
time you can see where myers is starting
that was the only concern whether or not
this was going to be an extra base hit
was how long it was in the air jake
myers made a catch where he reached out
at the last second caught it and slammed
into the wall hard that was impressive
that is a nice play rangers get a run
out of it a couple of sacrifice flies
and first pitch to the switch hitting
hernandez this one out into left field
again that's going to be trouble it
drops in base hit yani hernandez will
have extra bases trevino scores easily
it's five nothing man alive these
rangers bats
on fire this afternoon
and they get some breaks too i mean some
of these aren't hit
you know smoking line drives but they're
dropping in well they're putting the
ball in play and that is what yani
hernandez does best we talk a lot about
his lack of swing and miss he's got the
infield in he's just trying to get this
run in any way that he can
and he gets a pitch that he can handle
and
it's right down that left field line and
michael brantley he's getting a lot of
work out there in left field this
afternoon see how the rangers ship
jordan here to start the fifth inning
that ball hit high in the air deep to
right field with some carry that ball is
just foul
down the line in right no they're gonna
say that's a home run
jordan alvarez with a home run just
there down the right field line and the
astros are on the board with jordan's
28th home run of the year a big smile on
his face as he rounds third because the
way that you're done kind of went into
that carlton fisk lean as this ball goes
down the right field line 102.9 miles an
hour off the bat it kind of scooped it
and launched it you can see him kind of
leaning right there to see if that thing
would stay fair
and the only opportunity we had
it hit the foul pole oh wow there you go
home run number 28 a new career high
for jordan alvarez bettering his rookie
of the year total by one two outs astros
down by four
in the top of the fifth here's jake
myers who struck out his first time
myers hits the ball hard that'll be down
for a hit to the wall astros getting the
taylor heard here in the fifth inning a
home run a single a triple and now a
double they have hit for the cycle in
the fifth and they're back within three
it's five to two it's good to see this
asteroids offense come alive
they can do this to a pitcher they can
lay and wait
pick their moments and they're doing it
right now a big two out swing from jake
myers picking up jake myers swinging a
great bat another rbi for him as he gets
to 15. d.j peters to get it started for
texas here in the bottom half of the
fifth inning
this ball hit well by peters deep out to
center field meyers going back it is
gone
what a blast by dj peters
his seventh home run of the year
and the rangers back in front by four
this shot was a bomb to center field
breaking ball you can see the grip and
then hung up in the strike zone
and dj peters is all over you see his
eyes lighting up as he's making contact
and the damage is done look where this
ball lands it was a no doubter off the
bat of dj peters
payoff pitch that's grounded up the
middle that's a base hit
here comes solac around third he'll
score without a throw rbi single by
trevino and it is seven to two bases are
loaded and isaiah kinder philipe heading
to the plate
and that one lined out to right field
that's a base hit brings in a run and
it's eight to two the bases remain
loaded now for a goalie strong field and
that's in the air deep out to right
tucker is back welcome
there's your grand slam
adolese garcia
and the rangers have officially opened
up a can of whoop
not only the first grand slam of the
season for the rangers 29th home run of
the season for garcia a breaking ball
that looked like it was going up and it
was supposed to go down
and garcia hits himself a high home run
to right field but he continues the
onslaught of opposite field slugging
the ranger rookie does it again and he
does it again to the houston astros nick
solac at the plate
and this one out to center field low to
third base they will waving and so
solace drives in another run it is 13 to
two
eight different rangers have scored in
this fifth minute so taylor hearn exits
after six and two innings a career-high
89 pitches a career high he allows two
runs on six hits six strikeouts today
see demarcus evans come on now for his
22nd game of the year 30 strikeouts for
him so far this season a 4.76 era for
the right-hander
and a bouncer first base low has it and
these fans can exalt there it is it's a
final the scoreless ninth and the
rangers finish it off 13-2
[Applause]
[Applause]